22 avril 80 de paris rue marbeuf à morts
et 63 blessés
l'attentât jamais revendiqué restait
pourtant le seul dossier qui permet
aujourd'hui au juge bruguière la mise en
examen de carlos seulement douze ans
après les faits le 7 juin dernier grâce
à des éléments nouveaux fournis par la
hongrie aujourd'hui plus généreuse avec
ses archives qu'à l'époque du rideau de
fer
mais le juge bruguière ne peut entendre
juridiquement le terroriste pour les
autres dossiers des dossiers dont les
avocats des victimes ont réclamé la
réouverture
quelques semaines avant l'arrestation de
carlos on avait demandé à trois semaines
de l'ouverture des dossiers du capitole
de la gare saint-charles je pense que
c'est une chine trompeur et d'après mes
calculs carlos devrait être impliqué
dans au moins cinq affaires
d'autres événéments nouveau récemment
oui le jeu d'instruction avait rendu
visite aux autorités est allemandes et
le rapport de la statique et services
secrets y aura d'autre part ont permis à
mon avis des avancées significatives
la sphère de la gare saint-jean deux
affaires qui n'ont abouti qu'à des non
lieu faute de preuves
deux attentats l'un contre le capital en
mars 82 5 morts l'autre à marseille gare
saint-charles en 83 également cinq
personnes tuées pour la réouverture de
ces deux dossiers les charges nouvelles
nécessaire juge bruguière sont en sa
possession
grâce à la stasi la police politique de
l'ancienne allemagne de l'est qui a
donné la copie de notes échangés entre
les membres du groupe terroriste mettant
en cause carlos reste la sphère de la
rue toullier ou deux agents de la dst
ont été tuées à paris en 75 la
condamnation par contumace du terroriste
doit être notifiée par le parquet pour
le juger aujourd'hui la chancellerie le
procureur général bruno cotte et la
chambre des affaires criminelles et des
grâces se sont réunis pour savoir quelle
solution juridique adopté une décision
devrait être prise jeudi